Over the last few months we've been talking
about the trials and tribulations for independent
news and politics on Youtube and a viewer
posted on our subreddit a question that brings
up a really interesting point about all this,
which is might left wing youtube channels
like the David Pakman show and so many others.
Might we simply be collateral damage in the
serious fight against extremism on Youtube.
I want to take this seriously, but first let
me sort of catch you up on what's been going
on. If you haven't heard youtube over the
last year has been deprioritizing our content.
We have had a reduction by about two thirds
or more in terms of the views that we get
by Youtube Algorithms saying, Oh, you like
this other news and politics thing. Go and
check out the David Pakman show. They have
increasingly been saying, go and check out
CNNs youtube channel or Fox News's or the
mega corporate late night talk shows, not
the David Pakman show that costs us views
so it costs us money. Youtube has been limiting
monetization on anything considered even remotely
controversial or sensitive in nature. When
you cover news and politics, everything you
talk about is potentially sensitive or controversial
in nature, so that's not been good.
So then incomes sub, sub sub reddit user nudity,
which a the David Pakman show subreddit of
course@davidpakman.com slash red dit and Nudie
says, I recently became a new subscriber of
the David Pakman show, both because I want
to support the channel now that youtube is
demonetizing content and because I prefer
the ad free experience, I've experienced the
same issues that have been reported by David
Youtube suggestions inevitably lead me back
to American mainstream corporate media even
when I rarely follow up on those suggestions.
Super done with Rachel Maddow for example,
but they keep pushing her. However, this is
the key part. I don't consider the new youtube
algorithm to be a bad thing like many, many
others. I have had an anti, an angry anti-us
j w phase that was largely pushed by a youtube
algorithm that drove me from Sam Harris. Debate
debates, evangelicals videos to Sargon and
beyond.
Radicalization on youtube is a real problem.
David secular talk and a few other progressive
independent media shows might just be collateral
damage in a very necessary move to stop people
from being radicalized by a recommendations
mechanism that drives them into a far right
conspiratorial fake news swamp. I do hope,
David, we'll address this possible upside
of the new algorithm at some point in the
show. What if it helps stop Trump being reelected
in 2020 in a sense this viewer is exactly
right. Youtube didn't go out and say, we hate
independent news. Let's figure out a way to
hurt independent news or even more so let's
figure out a way to hurt left-wing news or
right wing news on Youtube. We are a collateral
damage, but not of youtube wanting to rid
itself of extremism because they think it's
the right thing. The truth is youtube as an
institution cares about what is profitable.
Extremism actually is very profitable in a
sense in terms of watch time when people get
stuck in these echo chamber rabbit holes of
extremist content. If the content is monetized,
it is massively profitable for Youtube. So
Youtube as an institution doesn't care about
extremism per se. We are collateral damage
of Youtube wanting to preserve its profit
and make as much money as possible. I talked
about this on the Joe Rogan program back in
June. The Path is simple. We want to make
money when advertisers get upset. We don't
make money as youtube to keep advertisers
happy. We need to pull monetization from extremist
and racist content and we need to make sure
that that content is less searchable and less
recommended. So let's put in place an algorithm
that white lists legacy corporate channels
and then basically just makes guesses about
independent content and yeah, the David Pakman
show and secular talk and others get caught
in that collateral damage.
Now there is a solution here. Channels like
ours could be white listed. The David Pakman
show covers things like white supremacy. We
cover racism, we cover breaking news, but
we do it in an FCC safe way and we are not
advocating for extremist and we are fighting
it. A real person or people could look at
our channel and say, we are going to white
list the David Pakman show so that we keep
recommending his videos to the algorithm within
the algorithm so that monetization continues
at a higher rate because we don't want him
to be collateral damage to everything that
we are doing. And in the meantime, over the
weekend, lots of people, I was surprised to
hear from some prominent people actually got
in touch with me and said, David, you've been
talking about this for a month. I am now seeing
it as well, how can I help? What can I do?
But in practice, the simplest thing, everybody
can do some version of fun, the shows you
want to support directly. That's what it is.
And I know people get mad and say, David,
I watched 20 shows. I can't support all of
them directly. You're asking me to spend $200
a month just on internet shows. Well then
pick a couple if you can afford it. If you
can't then don't. But the whole point is we
have a system in place membership patrion
which allows people to get around all of these
issues and just say, I like what you're doing.
I'm going to support it directly. You don't
have to worry about monetization or demonetization.
It doesn't have to be my show. That really
is the path forward. A lot of people have
been saying it for a long time and it's never
been more clear than the